Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It would require a greater philosopher and historian than I am to explain the causes of the famous Seven Years' War in which Europe was engaged. So wrote William Makepeace Thackeray in 1844 in his great novel The Luck of Barry Lyndon. Indeed, Thackeray goes on to say, Its origin has always appeared to me to be so complicated and the books written about it so amazingly hard to understand
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。要解释欧洲卷入著名的七年战争的原因，需要一位比我更伟大的哲学家和历史学家。威廉·梅克皮斯·萨克雷在 1844 年的伟大长篇小说《巴里·林登传》中这样写道。事实上，萨克雷接着说，它的起源在我看来总是如此复杂，关于它的书籍也令人惊讶地难以理解
that I have seldom been much wiser at the end of a chapter than at the beginning and so shall not trouble my reader with any personal disquisitions concerning the matter. Well, I have Dominic Sandbrook with me, of course. And Dominic, we relish a challenge, do we not? So we are going to engage with the causes of the Seven Years' War. Not only are we doing that, we are venturing into a real super league of podcasting situation now, aren't we? I mean, we really are now becoming an elite closed shop because our guest is not only an expert on the Seven Years' War, he is one of history's absolute elite.
以至于我在读完一章后，往往并不比开始时更明白，因此我不会用任何关于此事的个人论述来打扰我的读者。当然，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）和我在一起。多米尼克，我们喜欢挑战，不是吗？所以我们要探讨七年战争的起因。我们不仅在做这件事，我们现在还进入了播客界的超级联赛，不是吗？我的意思是，我们现在真的变成了一个精英封闭圈，因为我们的嘉宾不仅是七年战争的专家，他还是历史上绝对的精英。
He is the Real Madrid of history podcasts. Not that we're not Barcelona, but this is a podcast in Classico. Yes, it is, because we have with us Dan Snow, who... Dan, have you done podcasts before? No, this is my first.
他是历史播客界的皇家马德里。并不是说我们不是巴塞罗那，但这确实是一场国家德比式的播客。是的，确实如此，因为我们请来了丹·斯诺（Dan Snow），他……丹，你以前做过播客吗？不，这是我的第一次。
Can you hold my hand? I thrash myself to death doing podcasts, as you want To thrash myself to death doing podcasts as you want to because you've been on about 64. But more germainly, you are also the author of Death or Victory, The Battle of Quebec and the Birth of Empire, an absolutely splendid account of the Siege of Quebec, the Death of Wolfe, all that kind of stuff. So absolutely the perfect person to have on. But also, Dan, it's very exciting for us not just to have you on the show,
你能牵着我的手吗？我做播客做得要死，就像你想要的那样，因为你已经录了大约 64 期了。但更贴切地说，你还是《死亡或胜利：魁北克战役与帝国的诞生》（Death or Victory, The Battle of Quebec and the Birth of Empire）的作者，这是一部关于魁北克围城战、沃尔夫之死等事件的精彩记述。所以你绝对是我们要请的最完美的人选。而且，丹，不仅能请你上节目让我们感到非常兴奋，
but also to be doing an 18th century topic. Because I realise that although we've done, what, Dominic, about 40 odd episodes now, we haven't done one exclusively on the 18th century. And I think that's a real gap. Listeners, I am shaking my head with disappointment but not but not with surprise because tom what is it about the 18th century sandbrook's proclivity what is it about the 18th century what is it about the 18th century who would even ask that i tell you would ask that somebody writes books about the 1970s come on man
而且我们还能讨论一个 18 世纪的话题。因为我意识到，多米尼克，虽然我们现在已经做了大约 40 多期节目，但我们还没有专门做过一期关于 18 世纪的。我认为这是一个真正的空白。听众们，我失望地摇着头，但并不感到惊讶，因为汤姆，关于 18 世纪，桑德布鲁克的倾向是什么？关于 18 世纪，关于 18 世纪，谁会问这个问题？我告诉你，谁会问这个问题？写 20 世纪 70 年代书籍的人，拜托，伙计。
i mean but i i've given up on you a long time ago but holland i've always seen a spark i've always seen the spark of recognition despite his obsession with the ancient Near East. I've always deep down known that he's an 18th centuryist at heart and we could win him over. And it does get a decent heft in your new book, which I'm glad to see, Tom.
我的意思是，我很久以前就对你放弃了，但霍兰，我一直看到一丝火花，尽管他痴迷于古代近东，但我一直看到一丝认知的火花。我内心深处一直知道他本质上是一个 18 世纪研究者，我们可以争取他。而且你的新书里确实有相当大的篇幅涉及这个时期，我很高兴看到这一点，汤姆。
But the 18th century, first of all, obviously the important kicker here is that 18th century is steel, the best years of the centuries either side. So it's 1688, 1815, obviously is that 18th century is steel, the best years of the centuries either side. So it's 1688, 1815, obviously the long 18th century. This is when it all happens, guys. All these people focus on the 19th century, talking about your industrial revolution.
但 18 世纪，首先，这里显然重要的关键点是，18 世纪确实是前后两个世纪中最好的岁月。所以它是 1688 年到 1815 年，显然是漫长的 18 世纪。伙计们，这一切都发生在这个时期。所有这些人都关注 19 世纪，谈论你们的工业革命。
The industrial revolution is an 18th century phenomenon. That's where it begins. There are 17th centuryists now kind of picking up their phones, getting ready to tweet, so don't at me. And science, as we understand it, Newton, of course, 17th century, but it works in the 18th century. You've got Voltaire, you've got Hume, you've got Montesquieu, you have got Locke, you have got Wollstonecraft.
工业革命是 18 世纪的现象。这就是它的开端。现在有 17 世纪的研究者拿起手机准备发推特了，所以别针对我。还有科学，正如我们所理解的那样，牛顿当然是 17 世纪的，但它在 18 世纪发挥了作用。你有伏尔泰，你有休谟，你有孟德斯鸠，你有洛克，你有沃斯通克拉夫特。
This is when our modern world is being shaped. By the end of the 18th century, you've got people suggesting that working people and women should be allowed to vote. You have got a very strong abolitionist movement. The end of the 18th century has got the same kind of discourse. you know you've got people suggesting that working people and women should be allowed to vote you have got a very strong abolitionist movement the work the end of the 18th century has got the same kind of discourse and the american republic has been born the first republic successful republic governed by a written constitution i mean this is a transformation in the history of the human race and i always think you know there's there's you've triggered me now guys but i mean yeah he's off
这就是我们的现代世界被塑造的时候。到 18 世纪末，有人建议应该允许工人和妇女投票。你有一个非常强大的废奴运动。18 世纪末有着同样的论调。你知道，有人建议应该允许工人和妇女投票，你有一个非常强大的废奴运动，18 世纪末有着同样的论调，美利坚共和国已经诞生，这是第一个由成文宪法治理的成功的共和国，我的意思是，这是人类历史上的一个转变，我总是认为，你知道，你们现在触动了我，伙计们，但我的意思是，是的，他开始了。
he's off there are there are you know like birth of the um we're all starting things in the in the 18th in the 17th century and also there is a whole raft as you know of brilliant scholars telling us how fantastic the um early medieval and medieval scholars were at science but i do think it's fair to say that something quite dramatic happens at the end of the 17th and the 18th we get that we get a recognizably modern world and from the piston from the train from the from the piston that drives those trains along at the very beginning of the 17th century although i should say drives those steam engines along uh to landing on mars and launching a drone is is a direct direct line we're close an august an augustan achievement so so dan you've listed the amazing achievements of the 18th century the enlightenment is a direct, direct line. We're close. An Augustan achievement.
他开始了，你知道，就像……我们都在 17 世纪开始了一些事情，而且正如你们所知，有一大批杰出的学者告诉我们，早期的中世纪和中世纪学者在科学方面是多么出色，但我确实认为公平地说，在 17 世纪末和 18 世纪发生了一些非常戏剧性的事情，我们得到了一个可识别的现代世界，从活塞，从火车，从驱动那些火车前进的活塞，在 17 世纪初，尽管我应该说驱动那些蒸汽机前进，到登陆火星和发射无人机，这是一条直接的线索，我们很接近，这是一个奥古斯都式的成就。所以，丹，你列举了 18 世纪惊人的成就，启蒙运动是直接的线索。我们很接近。这是一个奥古斯都式的成就。
So, Dan, you've listed the amazing achievements of the 18th century, the Enlightenment, the seabed of the Industrial Revolution, of the American Revolution, of the French Revolution. We are focusing on a war. And we're focusing on what is actually a very, very important war, what could possibly be described as the First World War.
所以，丹，你列举了 18 世纪惊人的成就，启蒙运动，工业革命的温床，美国革命，法国革命。我们专注于一场战争。我们专注于一场实际上非常、非常重要的战争，它可能被描述为第一次世界大战。
Would you view the seven years war as a a conflict on a level with the napoleonic wars the first world war the second world war as one that shapes not just british history or french history or european history but global history much more important than those those i'm so glad you said so what a great claim i mean the yeah the first of all it sees the four great empires hapsburg hohenzollern uh romanov and ottoman empire just falling apart within two years no i i think no i obviously uh row back on that slightly i think the seven years was fundamentally important i think it look it stands shoulder to shoulder with those ones in India, in terms of which we can talk about
你会把七年战争看作是一场与拿破仑战争、第一次世界大战、第二次世界大战同等水平的冲突吗？它塑造的不仅仅是英国历史、法国历史或欧洲历史，而是全球历史？比那些更重要。我很高兴你这么说，多么伟大的主张。我的意思是，是的，首先，它见证了四大帝国——哈布斯堡、霍亨索伦、罗曼诺夫和奥斯曼帝国——在两年内分崩离析。不，我想，不，我显然稍微收回这一点，我认为七年战争至关重要，我认为它在印度与那些战争并驾齐驱，我们可以谈谈
the spread of Britishness, trading practices, legal practices, language governing practices in India, and of course, fundamentally in North America. It gives us an English speaking. We used to be able to say, when I wrote the book we could always talk about that kind of anglo-saxon ideas of government but of course now that is yeah i don't
英国性、贸易惯例、法律惯例、语言管理惯例在印度的传播，当然，根本上是在北美。它给了我们一个讲英语的……我们过去常说，当我写这本书时，我们总是可以谈论那种盎格鲁-撒克逊式的政府理念，但当然现在那是……是的，我
know i don't want to get into that particular point exactly that's cancelled but but it was quite a useful term for 18th century is to describe an english british way of of organizing societies uh and organizing uh economies and political economies. So I think it's fantastically important. But it is also part of this thing called the Second Hundred Years' War, which is much more interesting than the First Hundred Years' War, which is this extraordinary global conflict from 1688 to 1815 for global hegemony between, well, remaking Europe, but also global hegemony between Britain and its colonial competitors in the end, France. And that's a war that ends literally with the Duke of Wellington watering his horses in the Seine and sleeping with Napoleon's mistress.
不知道，我不想深入探讨那个特定的观点，那被取消了，但对于 18 世纪的研究者来说，这是一个描述组织社会、组织经济和政治经济的英式、英国式方式的相当有用的术语。所以我认为它非常重要。但它也是所谓的“第二次百年战争”的一部分，这比“第一次百年战争”有趣得多，这是一场从 1688 年到 1815 年之间，为了全球霸权而进行的非凡的全球冲突，好吧，重塑欧洲，但也是英国与其殖民竞争对手——最终是法国——之间的全球霸权之争。那场战争最终以威灵顿公爵在塞纳河边给他的马喂水并与拿破仑的情妇同床共枕而告终。
You know, that is an extraordinary conflict, no less dramatic than the flag that hangs on the Reichstag in 1945. And one of enormous importance. Is the Seven Years' War a war? Or is it, you know, is it the First World War? We know when it started. We kind of know when it ended, although it's slightly muddy. The Seven Years' War, is it a distinct war? I mean, there seem to be different dates about when it started.
你知道，那是一场非凡的冲突，其戏剧性不亚于 1945 年悬挂在国会大厦上的旗帜。而且具有巨大的重要性。七年战争是一场战争吗？还是说，你知道，它是第一次世界大战？我们知道它是什么时候开始的。我们大概知道它是什么时候结束的，尽管有点模糊。七年战争，它是一场独特的战争吗？我的意思是，关于它是什么时候开始的，似乎有不同的日期。
It's kind of piggybacking on different conflicts all across the world. Is it a distinct thing, do you think? I think you're trying to get me to talk about the third carnatic war here aren't you uh no sorry you're right you're right that old trap yeah i mean could we just just for those who are not familiar there's very few listening who are not familiar with the seven years war i mean the the dates as in the history book 1756 to 1763 although well yeah that's the thing isn't it are they yes dominic and you're both right but tom i don't don't you do stuff down there's not very few listening you've done really well you've you know it's been a big success it's a nice it's a nice little project for you and i think we should wind the podcast up now tom he's he's he's the wrong
它有点像是在世界各地不同冲突的基础上进行的。你认为它是一件独特的事情吗？我想你是想让我谈谈第三次卡纳提克战争，对吧？呃，不，抱歉，你是对的，你是对的，那个老陷阱。是的，我的意思是，我们能不能，只是为了那些不熟悉的人，很少有听众不熟悉七年战争，我的意思是，历史书上的日期是 1756 年到 1763 年，尽管，嗯，是的，这就是问题所在，不是吗？是的，多米尼克，你们俩都对，但汤姆，你别做那些……丹，听众很少，你做得很好，你知道，这是一个巨大的成功，这对你来说是一个不错的小项目，我认为我们现在应该结束这个播客了，汤姆，他是个错误的
guest let's be honest so no the one interesting that yes um it is a war the war in in india it is is a sort of parallel conflict and one that is only very vaguely linked to the war in the rest of the world and that's where we should point out that william pitt the older who was not prime minister uh during the seven years war he was sort of he but he was arguably the kind of global strategist the secretary of the sort of if you like the foreign secretary the person in charge of the strategy he he had very limited he did virtually nothing in india it is you do see the first british amazingly you see the first british redcoat regiment the first british army regiment arriving in india in this period to take part and take part very it plays a decisive role in this war. You also see Royal Navy ships in the Indian Ocean.
嘉宾，老实说。所以不，有趣的一点是，是的，嗯，它是一场战争，印度的战争是一种平行的冲突，而且与世界其他地方的战争只有非常模糊的联系，这就是我们应该指出威廉·皮特（老皮特）的地方，他在七年战争期间不是首相，他有点……但他可以说是那种全球战略家，外交大臣，如果你愿意的话，负责战略的人，他在印度几乎没有什么作为，你确实看到了第一支英国红衫军团，第一支英国陆军团在这一时期抵达印度参与其中，并发挥了决定性作用。你还看到了印度洋上的皇家海军舰艇。
But it takes months for information to get back and forth. So local commanders are acting on their own initiative. For example, in India, you get the Black Hole of Calcutta we want to talk about. That's a war that has been going on between effectively the kind of crumbling and semi-autonomautonomous narwab of Bengal and East India Company forces, when the British discover that there is also a war in Europe and North America has broken out, they then go on the offensive. Extraordinary action. The Royal Navy sails up to Chandanagar and buys a very expensive victory, smashing French power in Bengal. So they are related, but they're not all part of one great chichilian war rooms let's move bits around the map sort of strategy the war in north america is
但信息往返需要几个月的时间。所以当地指挥官是根据自己的主动权行事的。例如，在印度，你得到了我们想谈论的加尔各答黑洞事件。那是一场在孟加拉摇摇欲坠且半自治的纳瓦布与东印度公司军队之间实际上一直在进行的战争，当英国人发现欧洲和北美也爆发了战争时，他们随后转入进攻。非凡的行动。皇家海军航行到金德讷格尔，并以非常昂贵的代价取得了胜利，粉碎了法国在孟加拉的权力。所以它们是相关的，但它们并不是一个伟大的、像奇奇利亚式的作战室，让我们在地图上移动棋子那种战略的一部分。北美的战争是
fascinating because it begins this is unusual this war is that the great wars of europe the war of austrian succession uh in 1740 the war of spanish succession the williamite wars of 1790 1690 they tend to begin in Europe. This actually begins in North America. This is what's amazing about the Seven Years' War. It doesn't last seven years, you quite rightly point out. The fighting has been going on since at least 1754 in North America. In the Pennsylvania backcountry, this war, the shots that will ignite this global war,
迷人的，因为它开始了，这是不寻常的，这场战争是欧洲的大战争，1740 年的奥地利王位继承战争，西班牙王位继承战争，1690 年的威廉派战争，它们往往始于欧洲。这实际上始于北美。这就是七年战争令人惊奇的地方。它并没有持续七年，你非常正确地指出了这一点。战斗至少从 1754 年起就在北美进行了。在宾夕法尼亚的偏远地区，这场战争，将点燃这场全球战争的枪声，
are fired by a little band of American loyal, loyal colonial troops, loyal to King George II. Led by the young George Washington. It's unbelievable. It's so exciting. So George Washington is going in, a colonial militia from Virginia, head in. France claimed the whole of the Mississippi Valley, all the area drained by the Mississippi, which is a gigantic swath of the Brego.
是由一小群忠于乔治二世国王的美国殖民地军队开火的。由年轻的乔治·华盛顿领导。这令人难以置信。太令人兴奋了。所以乔治华盛顿进去了，一支来自弗吉尼亚的殖民地民兵，进去了。法国声称拥有整个密西西比河谷，所有密西西比河排水的地区，这是一个巨大的区域。
Is that because they wanted beaver? They wanted beaver, Tom. They wanted beaver. They had the fever. But, you know, and it's not the first time that that date has been made. I know. I just, I tried to work with that, but I just couldn't in the end.
这是因为他们想要海狸吗？他们想要海狸，汤姆。他们想要海狸。他们得了热病。但是，你知道，这不是第一次做出那个日期了。我知道。我只是，我试图用那个，但我最终还是做不到。
And so they, in fact we should come back to beavers, because that's what Voltaire was particularly rude about, beavers. But they claimed this giant swathe of north america new france britain had a tiny little stream a little sort of bit up the east coast the colonies on the east coast but there were lots more people in was ever densely populated um and inevitably lots of those people started crossing the allegheny mountains into the pennsylvania back country knocking into french forts um french traders and you get friction on the colonial frontier which is very familiar later in the into the Pennsylvania backcountry, knocking into French forts, French traders,
所以他们，事实上我们应该回到海狸的话题，因为那是伏尔泰特别粗鲁对待的东西，海狸。但他们声称拥有这片巨大的北美土地，新法兰西，英国只有一条小溪，东海岸的一点点，东海岸的殖民地，但那里的人口要多得多，而且不可避免地，许多人开始越过阿勒格尼山脉进入宾夕法尼亚的偏远地区，撞上法国的堡垒，法国的商人，你在殖民地边境遇到了摩擦，这在后来进入宾夕法尼亚偏远地区时非常熟悉，撞上法国的堡垒，法国的商人，
and you get friction on the colonial frontier, which is very familiar later in the 19th century. But that starts the Seven Years' War. You get fighting between Britain and France. And I've got to say, Perfidious Albion, extremely unimpressive. I mean, you get this. I hope, as you're hearing, by the way, that Thackeray was completely wrong. The Seven Years' War is very easy to understand. We haven't quite come to Europe yet, but in North America, it's quite straightforward. And then we haven't talked about Frederick the Great, which we must do.
你在殖民地边境遇到了摩擦，这在后来 19 世纪非常熟悉。但那开始了七年战争。你在英国和法国之间发生了战斗。我必须说，背信弃义的阿尔比恩，极其令人印象深刻。我的意思是，你得到了这个。我希望，顺便说一句，当你听到的时候，萨克雷完全错了。七年战争很容易理解。我们还没有完全来到欧洲，但在北美，它相当直接。然后我们还没有谈到腓特烈大帝，我们必须谈谈。
But in North America, there is fighting. And then, amazingly, the Royal Navy, France sends reinforcements to North America and the Royal Navy ambushes them, ambushes them, a brilliant Admiral Boscawan in 1755, captures two troop trips and fires on them before a declaration of war i mean it's pretty naughty stuff so we've got india and we've got america
但在北美，有战斗。然后，令人惊讶的是，皇家海军，法国向北美派遣增援部队，皇家海军伏击了他们，伏击了他们，杰出的博斯考恩海军上将在 1755 年，在宣战前俘获了两艘运兵船并向他们开火，我的意思是，这相当淘气。所以我们有印度，我们有美国，
but then we also have europe and you mentioned frederick the great and it's kind of interesting actually dominic thinking about it in this podcast frederick the great appeared in our very first podcast and he's popped up like a kind of specter on the margins yeah and he's he's i think i said before that that of all the kind of the the remarkable figures in history that i know very little about he's the one that i really want to know more about you keep working him in when he's not i mean you got him into you probably got him into the eunuchs podcast did you i think i missed him out of that that. But in the story of the Seven Years' War, Dan, Frederick the Great is kind of the key player on the Continental War.
但我们也有欧洲，你提到了腓特烈大帝，这实际上很有趣，多米尼克，考虑到在这个播客中，腓特烈大帝出现在我们的第一个播客中，他像边缘上的幽灵一样冒了出来。是的，我想我之前说过，在我所知道的所有历史上的杰出人物中，他是那个我真的想了解更多的人。你一直把他写进去，当他不在的时候，我的意思是，你可能把他写进了太监播客，对吧？我想我错过了那个。但在七年战争的故事中，丹，腓特烈大帝是大陆战争的关键人物。
He is. So tell us about him and what's going on there. Well, you're sounding now like the Duke of Newcastle, who was the Prime Minister in the Seven Years' War. Well, when the British finally found a stable governing coalition during the Seven Years' War, a very, very successful administration, one of the most successful administrations in British history. The Duke of Newcastle handled the money stuff, and William Pitt was then free to spend astonishing amounts of money,
他是。所以告诉我们关于他以及那里发生了什么。好吧，你现在听起来像纽卡斯尔公爵，他是七年战争期间的首相。好吧，当英国人终于在七年战争期间找到了一个稳定的执政联盟时，一个非常、非常成功的政府，英国历史上最成功的政府之一。纽卡斯尔公爵处理钱的问题，威廉·皮特随后可以自由地花费惊人的金钱，
like more money than the British have ever spent before on violence, waging war on several continents. The Duke of Newcastle, however, said, my price for doing that is I need to be focused on the war on the continent. So while you're stripping the French and later the Spanish of their colonies around the world, I need to support Frederick the Great in Europe. This is where it gets slightly complicated.
就像英国以前在暴力上花费的钱一样，在几个大陆上发动战争。然而，纽卡斯尔公爵说，我这样做的代价是我需要专注于大陆上的战争。所以当你在世界各地剥夺法国人，后来是西班牙人的殖民地时，我需要在欧洲支持腓特烈大帝。这就是事情变得有点复杂的地方。
Britain had Hanover. Hanover is this incredibly hard-to-defend state in North and West Germany. The King George II is the elector of Hanover, the Prince-Elector of Hanover. Hanover is this incredibly hard-to-defend state in North and West Germany. The King George II is the elector of Hanover, the Prince-Elector of Hanover. He says to Duke of Newcastle, you can run my administration, but for God's sake, keep the French out of Hanover. I want you to look after Hanover. So Duke of Newcastle says, fine, we will flip this great diplomatic, we have the so-called diplomatic revolution. We will pay the Prussians to protect Hanover from the French, which means unfortunately going to war against our, well, it means being on the other side from our old allies, the Austrians. So you've got Maria Theresa and her Austrian empire,
英国有汉诺威。汉诺威是德国北部和西部一个极其难以防御的州。乔治二世国王是汉诺威选帝侯，汉诺威的选帝侯亲王。汉诺威是德国北部和西部一个极其难以防御的州。乔治二世国王是汉诺威选帝侯，汉诺威的选帝侯亲王。他对纽卡斯尔公爵说，你可以管理我的政府，但看在上帝的份上，让法国人远离汉诺威。我需要你照顾汉诺威。所以纽卡斯尔公爵说，好吧，我们将扭转这个伟大的外交，我们有所谓的“外交革命”。我们将付钱给普鲁士人以保护汉诺威免受法国人的侵害，这意味着不幸的是要与我们的，嗯，这意味着要站在我们老盟友奥地利人的对立面。所以你有玛丽亚·特蕾莎和她的奥地利帝国，
Austria-Hungary, and the French fighting Frederick the Great, who's trying to enlarge Prussia. Over the course of Frederick the Great's life, Prussia doubles in size. Prussia becomes the thing that will eventually, as we know, go on to dominate Germany with some small consequences for 20th century history. And the Seven Years' War is part of Prussia. Frederick's view of an expanded Prussia being tested by fire. The Swedes invaded, the Russians invaded, Berlin was occupied, Maria Theresa's Austrians got their act together briefly and were able to inflict a few defeats on Frederick the Great. So Frederick the Great is fighting this unbelievably complicated war on all fronts in Europe, funded by the Brits, paid for by the Brits. He also dispatches one of his rather good generals to look after Hanover, and they do that very effectively. And Frederick
奥匈帝国，以及与腓特烈大帝作战的法国人，他正试图扩大普鲁士。在腓特烈大帝的一生中，普鲁士的规模扩大了一倍。普鲁士成为了最终，正如我们所知，将继续统治德国的东西，对 20 世纪历史产生了一些小的后果。而七年战争是普鲁士的一部分。腓特烈对一个扩张的普鲁士在火中接受考验的看法。瑞典人入侵了，俄国人入侵了，柏林被占领了，玛丽亚·特蕾莎的奥地利人短暂地团结起来，并能够对腓特烈大帝造成几次失败。所以腓特烈大帝正在欧洲各条战线上进行这场令人难以置信的复杂战争，由英国人资助，由英国人买单。他还派遣了他的一位相当优秀的将军去照顾汉诺威，他们非常有效地做到了这一点。而腓特烈
wins some stunning victories. The reason this war is completely different to the War of Austrian Succession, which has gone before, and various other wars, for example, the French Revolutionary Wars that almost kill William Pitt, they're very frustrating. They can't find anyone to beat Napoleon on the continent initially. What's brilliant about the Seven Years' War for Britain is they are able to do the things they're best at. They're able to send this Royal Navy slowly developing a marked advantage over, technically, in terms of their training, in terms of their tactical ability, over their competing European navies, the Spanish and the French. They're slowly getting qualitatively better, and they're quantitatively much better
赢得了一些惊人的胜利。这场战争与之前的奥地利王位继承战争以及其他各种战争（例如几乎杀死威廉·皮特的法国大革命战争）完全不同的原因是，它们非常令人沮丧。他们最初在大陆上找不到任何人能击败拿破仑。七年战争对英国来说之所以精彩，是因为他们能够做他们最擅长的事情。他们能够派遣这支皇家海军，在技术上，在他们的训练方面，在他们的战术能力方面，相对于他们竞争的欧洲海军（西班牙和法国），慢慢地发展出明显的优势。他们慢慢地在质量上变得更好，而在数量上他们要好得多
because they spend more money on it. So they're allowed to go and do that. They capture all sorts of colonies everywhere, from Cuba to the Philippines extraordinary the greatest run of success in British history although with a predictably British slow start which we could also come to it's fascinating this of second world war Napoleon it was first of all there's always a kind of there's also a warming up period required to the British war which is so interesting which has probably got something to do with the channel and the space that Britain has to sort of take its time. Anyway, but on the continent, Frederick the Great is able to defeat all comers in the most extraordinarily dramatic series of campaigns.
因为他们在这上面花了更多的钱。所以他们被允许去那样做。他们俘获了世界各地的各种殖民地，从古巴到菲律宾，这是英国历史上最伟大的成功，尽管有一个可预见的英国式缓慢开端，我们也可以谈谈这一点。这很有趣，这场第二次世界大战，拿破仑，首先，英国战争总是需要一个热身期，这非常有趣，这可能与海峡和英国必须花时间的空间有关。无论如何，但在大陆上，腓特烈大帝能够在一系列极其戏剧性的战役中击败所有来犯者。
And so it is said at the time that the British Empire in North America was won on the battlefields of Germany. So it's this extraordinary combination. But Dan, we have troops in Europe too, don't we? Aren't they commanded by the Marquess of Granby? Aren't all those pubs named after the... You know, he's only remembered as a pub now, but at the time he's, isn't he leading our troops in Europe? Am I wrong?
所以当时有人说，北美的大英帝国是在德国的战场上赢得的。所以这是一个非凡的组合。但丹，我们在欧洲也有军队，不是吗？他们不是由格兰比侯爵指挥的吗？那些酒吧不是都以……你知道，他现在只被记住为一个酒吧，但在当时，他不是在领导我们在欧洲的军队吗？我错了吗？
Pub signs are very, the Seven Years' War is more around us than we might think. So, you know, there are pub signs, the Prince of Prussia, the Marquess of Granby, all those pub signs are anything to do with Wolfe. There were more pubs about General Wolfe in the past, but those pub signs are all, yes, from this period. There was a battle, a great forgotten battle of British history. It's another one of the, we could talk about the year 1759, Annus Mirabilis, the most successful year in British history, when the Battle of Minden took place,
酒吧招牌非常，七年战争在我们周围比我们想象的要多。所以，你知道，有酒吧招牌，普鲁士亲王，格兰比侯爵，所有那些酒吧招牌都与沃尔夫有关。过去有更多关于沃尔夫将军的酒吧，但那些酒吧招牌都是，是的，来自这一时期。有一场战斗，一场英国历史上伟大的被遗忘的战斗。这是另一个，我们可以谈谈 1759 年，奇迹之年，英国历史上最成功的一年，当时明登战役发生了，
when the French were decisively defeated on the continent. But there were many British forces there not under under kind of coalition control this kind of prussian coalition um command and and so it doesn't it isn't it's weird it doesn't it's not one of those sort of british battles that really excites but it's hugely important what it does is it basically pins down french forces in europe stops the French doing what they usually do, which is get completely hammered in the colonies in India, in North America. They lose Louisbourg, for example, the huge fortress at the mouth of the St. Lawrence River in the War of the Austro-History. But then the French basically invade Belgium and the Netherlands and various other places. And Britain, in order to restore the Bancs out, in order to kind of compress France into a manageable size,
当时法国人在大陆上被决定性地击败了。但那里有许多英国军队不在某种联盟控制之下，这种普鲁士联盟的指挥，所以它不是，它很奇怪，它不是那种真正让人兴奋的英国战斗之一，但它非常重要，它所做的是它基本上把法国军队钉在了欧洲，阻止了法国人做他们通常做的事情，那就是在印度、北美的殖民地被彻底痛打。例如，他们在奥地利王位继承战争中失去了路易斯堡，那个位于圣劳伦斯河口的巨大堡垒。但随后法国人基本上入侵了比利时和荷兰以及其他各种地方。而英国，为了恢复平衡，为了以某种方式将法国压缩成一个可管理的规模，
this great and enduring problem of English and British strategy makers, policy makers, in order to compress France back down, you have to sacrifice all these colonial gains. The key difference with the Seven Years' War is you can keep more of your colonial gains at the end because Frederick the Great and this army in Hanover have have have catastrophic defeat in france in europe they've the bit that the french are usually good at they've done badly at so they've got no chips on the table at the end of the at the end of the day okay should we should we focus on the year of victories yeah let's do
这个英国和英国战略制定者、政策制定者长期存在的问题，为了将法国压缩回去，你必须牺牲所有这些殖民地收益。七年战争的关键区别在于，你可以在最后保留更多的殖民地收益，因为腓特烈大帝和这支在汉诺威的军队在欧洲对法国造成了灾难性的失败，他们，法国人通常擅长的部分，他们做得不好，所以他们在一天结束时桌上没有筹码。好吧，我们应该，我们应该专注于胜利之年吗？是的，让我们做
that that's kind of feel why not um so so this is a year of absolutely storming british victories over the french um dan give us all a patriotic thrill by bye bye we don't have any french listeners do we tom not that i'm aware of maybe not well apologies if we do um well not anymore by going through um the full scale of of what happens in that year. So there's a very odd and predictive... As I say, there's this kind of classic British slow start. They lose Menorca. And Admiral Bing gets hanged to encourage the others, doesn't he? Well, he gets shot on his own quarter-deck.
那个，那感觉为什么不呢，所以，这是一个英国对法国取得绝对性胜利的一年，丹，给我们所有的爱国快感，再见，再见，我们没有法国听众，对吧，汤姆？据我所知没有，也许没有，好吧，如果我们有的话，道歉，嗯，好吧，不再有了，通过回顾那一年的全部规模。所以有一个非常奇怪和预测性的……正如我所说，有一种经典的英国式缓慢开端。他们失去了梅诺卡岛。而宾海军上将被绞死以鼓励其他人，不是吗？好吧，他在自己的后甲板上被枪决了。
Voltaire quips to encourage the others. And things go badly in North America. The Marquis de Montcalm, you may have seen the film Last of the Mexicans, he manages to beat the French out of Fort William Henry. Basically, there's an invasion corridor between what is now the USA and France, up Lake Champlain, this wonderful sort of, it links Albany to Montreal, basically. And so for hundreds of years, the French and British, of course, overlooked but fundamentally important Native American allies,
伏尔泰打趣说“以鼓励其他人”。事情在北美进展不顺。蒙卡尔姆侯爵，你可能看过电影《最后的莫希干人》，他设法把法国人赶出了威廉亨利堡。基本上，在现在的美国和法国之间有一条入侵走廊，沿着尚普兰湖，这种美妙的，它基本上连接了奥尔巴尼和蒙特利尔。所以几百年来，法国人和英国人，当然还有被忽视但至关重要的美洲原住民盟友，
have marched up and down this invasion corridor and it like a tide coming sort of receding and advancing and the French march down they successfully take Fort William Henry that many of the surrendering garrison are massacred as depicted and Daniel Lewis does his stuff so that's a kind of and and Britain also the Mohicans and all that that's the Mohicans uh yeah I should have mentioned right dropping Daniel de Luyssen there was probably slightly obscure. Then Edward Braddock and George Washington again. They're annihilated. One of the greatest defeats in British history in 1755.
都在这条入侵走廊上行军，就像潮水一样退去和前进，法国人向下行军，他们成功地占领了威廉亨利堡，许多投降的驻军被屠杀，正如所描绘的那样，丹尼尔·刘易斯做了他的事情，所以那是一种，而且英国也，莫希干人等等，那是莫希干人，是的，我应该提到，把丹尼尔·刘易斯放进去可能有点晦涩。然后是爱德华·布拉多克和乔治·华盛顿。他们在 1755 年被歼灭。英国历史上最伟大的失败之一。
So George Washington seems absolutely terrible. He's terrible. He's terrible. Listen, we could do another podcast about George Washington. I mean, my God. Yeah, okay. He just rushes around losing battles. But you know what? He's young, Tom. He's's young he makes his mistakes early and he learns a lot he learns a lot okay and then he performs reasonably after that uh and he and that
所以乔治华盛顿看起来绝对糟糕。他很糟糕。他很糟糕。听着，我们可以做另一个关于乔治华盛顿的播客。我的天。是的，好吧。他只是到处乱跑，输掉战斗。但你知道吗？他还年轻，汤姆。他还年轻，他早早地犯了错误，他学到了很多，他学到了很多，好吧，然后他在那之后表现得相当不错，而且他，那个
should have been the end of him really um if it hadn't been for the bloody post seven years war fiasco but anyway we'll come to that we'll come to that so won't we? We'll come to that. So then in 1759, everything kind of falls into place. And the reason is that it's money. It's money. It's the giant spending by the British government, the famous fiscal military states that the 18th century historians like to talk about, where these states have come into being, very modern states, where you can borrow at low interest rates because you've got a faintly reliable –
那本应该是他的终点，如果不是因为该死的七年战争后的惨败，但无论如何，我们会谈到那个，我们会谈到那个，不是吗？我们会谈到那个。所以然后在 1759 年，一切都各就各位了。原因就是钱。是钱。这是英国政府的巨额支出，18 世纪历史学家喜欢谈论的著名的财政军事国家，这些国家已经形成，非常现代的国家，你可以以低利率借款，因为你有一个稍微可靠的——
the lenders are suitably confident that you're going to get that money back. There is a legal system, there's a political, you can seek redress within Parliament. It is far from being a very modern, sort of completely, you know, brilliant, sort of a very modern state in which things are perfectly transparent. But it is groping towards that place so britain can borrow even though it's a smaller economy uh it can borrow titanic amounts of money which is unavailable to the french because they're mad uh you know ancien regime despots who just choose not to pay it back or or spend it on stupid things like enormous palaces whereas whereas the british can say to people lend us money we're going to spend it on ships that will protect trade and you will
贷款人非常确信你会把钱还回来。有一个法律体系，有一个政治体系，你可以在议会内寻求补救。它远不是一个非常现代的、某种完全的、你知道，辉煌的、某种非常现代的国家，其中事情是完全透明的。但它正在摸索着走向那个地方，所以英国可以借款，即使它是一个较小的经济体，它也可以借入巨额资金，这对于法国人来说是不可用的，因为他们疯了，你知道，旧制度的专制者，他们只是选择不还钱，或者把钱花在愚蠢的事情上，比如巨大的宫殿，而英国人可以对人们说，借钱给我们，我们将把它花在保护贸易的船只上，你将
then benefit from that trade and we will make money on the tax that derives from that trade so there's a there's a system that works so so Pitt and Newcastle and the British government are able to send huge amounts of ships and men to all these theatres at once that's what's so extraordinary about this they're able to keep the war going in Europe whilst also dispatching the biggest expeditionary force in in history really to North America um and and. And that means that by 1758, there's a bit of a stuttering start. But 1759, it all comes into place. A young British officer called James Cook, again, interesting character here, grows up in a kind of illiterate, very marginal family. He goes to sea um on the coal trade newcastle
然后从那种贸易中受益，我们将从那种贸易产生的税收中赚钱，所以有一个有效的系统，所以皮特和纽卡斯尔以及英国政府能够同时向所有这些战区派遣大量的船只和人员，这就是这场战争如此非凡的地方，他们能够保持欧洲的战争，同时派遣历史上真正最大的远征军到北美，而且。这意味着到 1758 年，有一个有点磕磕绊绊的开始。但 1759 年，一切都各就各位了。一个叫詹姆斯·库克的年轻英国军官，同样，这里有一个有趣的人物，在一个文盲、非常边缘化的家庭中长大。他出海，在纽卡斯尔的煤炭贸易中，
supplying london with coal this kind of giant industrial city in the south accessing the saudi arabia of energy in the 18th century which is the coal fields northumberland um he learns his trade there and brutally difficult navigational pilotage conditions he then joins the navy volunteers join the navy on the outbreak and is rapidly promoted joins as an ordinary seaman, but rapidly promoted, becomes an officer. So again, the Royal Navy, an engine of meritocracy in this period. Imperfect, but key to its success. James Cook creates the first chart of the St. Lawrence River. St. Lawrence River, vast, complicated river running into the heart of Canada. The French never bothered, they didn't really bother defending it. They said, oh, it's impossible.
为伦敦供应煤炭，这个 18 世纪南部的巨大工业城市，获取 18 世纪的能源沙特阿拉伯，也就是诺森伯兰的煤田，他在那里学习了他的贸易，在极其困难的航海领航条件下，他随后加入了海军，在战争爆发时志愿加入海军，并迅速晋升，作为一名普通水手加入，但迅速晋升，成为一名军官。所以再次，皇家海军，这一时期的精英管理引擎。不完美，但对其成功至关重要。詹姆斯·库克绘制了圣劳伦斯河的第一张海图。圣劳伦斯河，广阔、复杂的河流流入加拿大的中心。法国人从不费心，他们并没有真正费心去保卫它。他们说，哦，这不可能。
Only the pilots now to get up and down. You know, you need the local knowledge passed down from the sun. James Cook says, no, no, no. He creates the first chart. And the British astonish the French by arriving in Quebec, the capital of their empire in New France, in front of the walls of Quebec with a gigantic fleet and with a huge number of troops on board and stay there the whole summer. It's actually quite a complicated summer. And it's as Tom, who's one of the only, who's one of the three people on this earth
只有领航员现在才能上下。你知道，你需要从儿子那里传下来的当地知识。詹姆斯·库克说，不，不，不。他绘制了第一张海图。英国人让法国人感到惊讶，他们抵达了魁北克，他们在新法兰西帝国的首都，在魁北克城墙前，带着一支巨大的舰队和船上大量的军队，并在那里待了整个夏天。这实际上是一个相当复杂的夏天。而且正如汤姆，他是地球上仅有的三个人之一
outside my immediate family that read my book 10 years ago, for which I'm eternally grateful, Tom. I've read your book, Dan. And so they eventually take... It's good. It's a really good book. Come on. Why do you think nobody read it? Well, because I have access to data. uh data no listen we're not getting it unjustly neglected books i'm sure you're right up the bestseller list again yeah exactly okay so they so they
在我直系亲属之外，10 年前读过我的书，我对此永远感激不尽，汤姆。我读过你的书，丹。所以他们最终占领了……这很好。这真的是一本好书。拜托。你为什么认为没人读它？好吧，因为我有数据访问权限。呃，数据，不，听着，我们不会谈论被不公正忽视的书籍，我相信你又回到了畅销书榜单上，是的，完全正确，好吧，所以他们，所以他们
capture quebec eventually absolute nightmare terrifyingly difficult they almost all die of typhus and dysentery and the rest of it. They all fall out with each other. James Wolfe is deeply unpopular with his fellow commanders and subordinates. It's not arguably not really his plan, in fact, that they eventually land at this
最终占领了魁北克，绝对是噩梦，极其困难，他们几乎都死于斑疹伤寒和痢疾等等。他们都和彼此闹翻了。詹姆斯·沃尔夫在同事和下属中非常不受欢迎。可以说这实际上并不是他的计划，事实上，他们最终降落在这个
very lightly defended... They use... It's amphibious. It's what Britain does really well. It's what they've done well in India. It's what they're going to do well in the Caribbean. It's what they do well all the way up until deep into the 20th century. They do it in China in the 19th century. They use this extraordinary navy. And the navy, we think of the navy sailing around big battleships in deep water.
防御非常薄弱的……他们使用……这是两栖的。这是英国人非常擅长的事情。这是他们在印度做得很好的事情。这是他们将在加勒比海做得很好的事情。这是他们一直做得很好的事情，直到 20 世纪深处。他们在 19 世纪在中国做到了。他们使用这支非凡的海军。而且海军，我们认为海军在深水中航行大型战列舰。
The navy, this is about small boats in very shallow water penetrating deep into the heart of continents. They land. These are highlanders and they scale up the heights of Abraham. They catch the French by surprise and they defeat the French army on the heart of continents. They land. These are Highlanders, and they scale up the heights of Abraham. They catch the French by surprise, and they defeat the French army on the plains of Abraham. And Wolf is killed. That's the thing you always should do in life
海军，这是关于在非常浅的水域中的小船，深入大陆的心脏。他们降落了。这些是高地人，他们爬上了亚伯拉罕高地。他们让法国人措手不及，并在大陆的心脏地带击败了法国军队。他们降落了。这些是高地人，他们爬上了亚伯拉罕高地。他们让法国人措手不及，并在亚伯拉罕平原上击败了法国军队。而沃尔夫被杀了。这是你一生中总是应该做的事情
if you're a commander. Nelson does it. Wellington fails to do it stupidly. Gordon does it. And he's killed at the moment of victory. And he's deified. He also has these fantastic lines, doesn't he? What is it?
如果你是一名指挥官。纳尔逊做到了。威灵顿愚蠢地失败了。戈登做到了。他在胜利的那一刻被杀。他被神化了。他也有这些精彩的台词，不是吗？是什么？
Now God be praised, I can die in peace, or something, when he's told the French are running before him. Is this true? And he should be painted looking like a martyr. Well, he's then painted by Benjamin West, who famously then later paints Nelson. And that becomes, I think, the most widely distributed image of the 18th century. I mean, it is, rule rule britannia this is a this is a kind of crucible for um a britishness that because that we that we recognize you know this is a kind of a tempting to use the word nationalist but
现在上帝被赞美，我可以平静地死去，或者类似的话，当他被告知法国人在他面前逃跑时。这是真的吗？他应该被画得看起来像个烈士。好吧，他随后被本杰明·韦斯特画了下来，后者后来著名地画了纳尔逊。这成为了，我认为，18 世纪分布最广的图像。我的意思是，它是，统治吧，不列颠尼亚，这是一个，这是一个，一种试图使用“民族主义”这个词，但
that's that's probably a little bit anachronistic but it's it's this idea that britain that god was an englishman that britain had Exactly, and we've all read Linda Colley, and Royal Britannia becomes... And Magna Carta is displayed by the way, during this period, famously. The British Museum is a-founded, and Magna Carta is put on a huge, big public display in the British Museum, and it's just
那，那可能有点时代错误，但它是，它是这个想法，英国，上帝是一个英国人，英国有，完全正确，我们都读过琳达·科利，而《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》成为了……顺便说一句，大宪章在这一时期被展示，著名地。大英博物馆成立了，大宪章在大英博物馆进行了巨大的、大型的公开展示，而且它只是
labelled as the Bulwark of Our Liberties. And so there's this link between monumental warfare, British success on the battlefield, there's an Anglo-Scottish element here, because lots of these British troops are former Jacobite soldiers who are now fighting for the British crown. And Highlanders. Highlanders, exactly. So there's a really interesting kind of British story emerging here. And then this idea of kind of English-British exceptionalism as well through Magna Carta, through museums, all that kind of stuff.
被称为我们自由的堡垒。因此，纪念碑式的战争与英国在战场上的成功之间存在着这种联系，这里还有一个英格兰-苏格兰的因素，因为许多这些英国军队都是前詹姆斯党士兵，现在正为英国王室而战。还有高地人。没错，就是高地人。所以这里出现了一种非常有趣的英国故事。然后还有通过大宪章、博物馆等所有这些东西所体现出的那种英格兰-英国例外论。
So it's really interesting. Then, one of the most remarkable moments of 1759, as well as, by the way, Frederick the Great is at the moment in Europe contemplating suicide. He's doing so badly. Like Hitler, right? So this is the bit that Hitler in the bunker
所以这真的很有趣。然后，1759年最引人注目的时刻之一，顺便说一下，腓特烈大帝当时在欧洲正考虑自杀。他处境非常糟糕。就像希特勒一样，对吧？所以这就是希特勒在地堡里
is reading up on Frederick the Great and getting inspiration from it. Right, because Frederick the Great had lost Berlin by this stage. He's lost half his army in one particular battle. It is absolutely, he's been crushed, but he's been kept in the field by British money. And then the most extraordinary thing ever, which is the Tsar dies, the Tsarina dies. And this new Tsar comes in who just likes Frederick the Great and just unilaterally leaves his alliance with Maria Theresa.
阅读关于腓特烈大帝的书并从中获得灵感的那部分。没错，因为腓特烈大帝当时已经失去了柏林。他在一场特定的战役中损失了一半的军队。他简直是被彻底粉碎了，但他靠英国的资金留在了战场上。然后发生了有史以来最非凡的事情，那就是沙皇去世了，女沙皇去世了。而这位新上任的沙皇恰好喜欢腓特烈大帝，并单方面退出了与玛丽亚·特蕾莎的联盟。
I mean, Maria Theresa's one of the most long-suffering and remarkable women in the history of the world, and that's up against some pretty tough competition. And she, as she's on the verge of victory, this idiotic, childlike Russian Tsar, reverses. Exactly. He is then got rid of by catherine the great uh his wife but not before he's lent a big chunk of his army to frederick and and basically got frederick
我的意思是，玛丽亚·特蕾莎是世界历史上最坚忍、最杰出的女性之一，而且是在面对相当严峻的竞争对手的情况下。当她即将取得胜利时，这个愚蠢、孩子气的俄罗斯沙皇却反悔了。没错。他后来被他的妻子叶卡捷琳娜大帝除掉了，但在那之前，他把大批军队借给了腓特烈，基本上让腓特烈
out of the out of trouble so so europe's just stable enough for the british to mop up everywhere else they capture guard loot they capture a chunk of west africa slave trading ports in west africa uh and uh slave wasn't slave trading slave gathering fortresses in west Africa, and slave, wasn't slave trading, slave gathering fortresses in West Africa. And then at the end of the year, just when things couldn't have gone any better at all, you get this bizarre, you get this extraordinary moment, the greatest naval battle in British history, which people should know about and they don't, which is the Battle of Kiberon Bay, which Sir Edward Hawke, I mean, Nelson, dare I, okay, listen, I mean, I'm a big Nelson
摆脱了困境，所以欧洲的局势刚好稳定到足以让英国人去清理其他地方，他们占领了加德，掠夺了西非的一大片地区，奴隶贸易港口在西非，呃，奴隶，不是奴隶贸易，是西非的奴隶聚集堡垒，还有，奴隶，不是奴隶贸易，是西非的奴隶聚集堡垒。然后在年底，就在一切进展得不能再好的时候，你遇到了这个离奇的、非凡的时刻，英国历史上最伟大的海战，人们应该知道却不知道的，那就是基伯龙湾海战，爱德华·霍克爵士，我的意思是，纳尔逊，我敢说，好吧，听着，我的意思是，我是纳尔逊的忠实粉丝
Fowler's the next guy. I don't think I- He's about to knock Nelson. He's gearing up to knock Nelson. This is the excitement of podcasts. They're so daring. You just don't know, do you? You don't know what's going to happen next.
福勒是下一个人。我不认为我——他正要抨击纳尔逊。他正准备抨击纳尔逊。这就是播客的刺激之处。它们太大胆了。你就是不知道，对吧？你不知道接下来会发生什么。
Nelson commanded a detached fleet. He was not in charge of the Channel Squadron. He could do what he liked. It was fine. He was down in the Mediterranean. He could take a few gambles. Sir Edward Hawke is commanding the Royal Naval Fleet responsible for
纳尔逊指挥着一支独立舰队。他并不负责海峡中队。他可以随心所欲。这没问题。他在地中海。他可以冒一些险。爱德华·霍克爵士指挥着皇家海军舰队，负责
protecting the british isles against french invasion okay and yet and he finds that the french fleet have sailed they're going to join up with their transports big problem with geography by the way is there is no port this is why god is in fact an englishman there is no port in northern france which can have a large army sitting in it and is deep enough for battleships all to be at the same time you have breast which is bad by the way for the wind but you have breast but there is not enough food in that tiny tip of britain you think about where breast is on the tip of britain it's bloody miles away from anywhere else in france you can't take enough food there so you've got this permanent problem with trying to invade england which you have to keep the transports contain the soldiers
保护不列颠群岛免受法国入侵，好吧，然而他发现法国舰队已经起航，他们要与运输船队会合。顺便说一下，地理上的一个大问题是，没有港口，这就是为什么上帝实际上是个英国人，法国北部没有一个港口既能容纳一支庞大的军队，又足够深，能同时停泊战列舰。你有布雷斯特，顺便说一下，这对风向来说很糟糕，但你有布雷斯特，但在布列塔尼那个小尖角上没有足够的食物，你想想布雷斯特在布列塔尼的尖角上，它离法国其他任何地方都远得要命，你无法在那里运送足够的食物，所以你一直面临着试图入侵英国的问题，你必须保持运输船队，控制士兵
in a different place the big battleships they've got rubbish harbours in northern France, which is why, following the Seven Years' War, the King of France decides to try and build Cherbourg as a massive seawall to create a port capable of taking on the British and bankrupt the French regime by doing that. And everyone said he was throwing rocks into the sea and throwing his money into the sea. Anyway, we'll come back to that. So the fleet has sailed.
在不同的地方，那些大型战列舰，他们在法国北部有糟糕的港口，这就是为什么在七年战争之后，法国国王决定尝试建造瑟堡作为一个巨大的防波堤，以建立一个能够对抗英国人的港口，并因此使法国政权破产。每个人都说他是在往海里扔石头，把钱扔进海里。总之，我们稍后再谈这个。所以舰队已经起航了。
They're meeting up with the transports. Hawke intercepts them. And in November, in a rising gale in november off a brutal coast of quiberon bay famously littered with shoals and rocks and inlets hawk says cram on more sail we are going to sail into quiberon bay uncharted territory basically for the brits we're going to follow those french who are hiding in there they think they're getting away from us as the as this autumnal gale is rising as the sun is setting and at sunset hawk scores this astonishing victory against the french ships capsizing in the wind just amazing story in amongst the rocks of key bronbe and dan is that like is that because
他们正在与运输船队会合。霍克拦截了他们。在十一月，在基伯龙湾残酷海岸外升起的狂风中，那里以浅滩、岩石和入口而闻名，霍克说，多挂帆，我们要驶入基伯龙湾，这基本上是英国人的未知领域，我们要跟随那些躲在那里的法国人，他们以为他们能逃脱我们，随着秋季的狂风升起，太阳落山，在日落时分，霍克对法国船只取得了这场惊人的胜利，它们在风中倾覆，在基伯龙湾的岩石中，真是太神奇的故事了，丹，那是像
it's it's it's like um going up the st lawrence river that the navy have the charts that enable them to negotiate the shoals or is it just kind oh, we're going to take a punt on this? It's a bit of both. First of all, it's certainly like the Navy going up the St. Lawrence River, a confidence in the seamanship of your naval ratings and officers. What is also happening is for the first successful time in the Seven Years' War, which is astonishingly important and a dramatic innovation, is all of the, again again the modernity of this state its ability to create systems you for the first time in ever you have a you have a successful blockade of french ports you you don't just say we're going to keep an eye on the french and when they come out we're going to fight them
那是像……沿着圣劳伦斯河航行，海军有能让他们避开浅滩的海图，还是说这只是一种“哦，我们要赌一把”？这有点两者兼有。首先，这当然就像海军沿着圣劳伦斯河航行，是对你的海军士兵和军官航海技术的信心。同时发生的事情是，在七年战争中第一次成功，这非常重要，是一个戏剧性的创新，那就是所有这些，再次强调这个国家的现代性，它建立系统的能力，你第一次有了对法国港口的成功封锁，你不仅仅是说我们要盯着法国人，当他们出来时我们要和他们战斗
you say they will not leave port we will blockade them in for not just weeks but for months and years so their sailors will not be trained their ships will rot at that you know they will lose their morale this is this is this is the first yes try out of a strategy that's been used in the polionic wars first world war it's tried earlier but after three weeks these ships come back everyone's got scurvy it's just the crews are falling you destroy your own fleet by blockading that's the problem dan we need to take a break our listeners will be they need a they need to have a swig of grog or something yeah comfort break and then they can return and a lemon but but i think i mean we've covered we basically
你说他们将无法离开港口，我们将封锁他们，不是几周，而是几个月甚至几年，这样他们的水手就不会受过训练，他们的船只会在那里腐烂，你知道他们会士气低落，这是这是这是第一次尝试一种在拿破仑战争、第一次世界大战中使用的策略，它之前也尝试过，但三周后这些船就回来了，每个人都得了坏血病，船员们都在倒下，你通过封锁摧毁了自己的舰队，这就是问题所在，丹，我们需要休息一下，我们的听众会，他们需要喝口朗姆酒之类的，是的，舒适休息，然后他们可以回来，还有柠檬，但我认为，我的意思是，我们已经涵盖了，我们基本上
we've covered the the sweep of the of the war um and when we come back perhaps we've got some questions and we can try and put all this in in the in the slightly broader perspective when your visitors go for a drink, let them remember the toast of the Royal Navy that derives straight from this period. May our officers have the eye of a hawk and the heart of a wolf. A splendid note, a splendid note on which to go to a commercial break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我们已经涵盖了战争的范围，当我们回来时，也许我们有一些问题，我们可以尝试把所有这些放在一个稍微更广阔的视角中，当你的访客去喝一杯时，让他们记住皇家海军的祝酒词，这直接源于这一时期。愿我们的军官拥有鹰的眼睛和狼的心。这是一个精彩的注脚，一个精彩的注脚，可以进入商业广告时间。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and The Seven Years' War. We're with Dan Snow talking about it. Dan, so you gave us a brilliant account of the course of the war and we were majoring on the scale of British triumphs. And for generations, these triumphs have been kind of iconic. So we talked about the death of Wolfe,
你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》和《七年战争》。我们和丹·斯诺一起谈论它。丹，你给了我们一个关于战争进程的精彩叙述，我们主要关注的是英国胜利的规模。几代人以来，这些胜利一直被视为标志性的。所以我们谈到了沃尔夫的死亡，
Battle of Quiberon Bay, also the Battle of Plassey, where Clive of India kind of basically wins, as it turns out, India for the nascent British Empire. So great scenes that have long been celebrated. However, I think it's fair to say that the idea that this is necessarily great for the world is now more contested than it was. So the idea that Clive of India has a statue in Whitehall, there are grumblings about it. Do you think that that is one of the reasons why the Seven Years' War has been generally forgotten. And is it kind of now problematic in a way that perhaps it wasn't for the earlier generations?
基伯龙湾海战，还有普拉西战役，克莱夫在印度基本上赢得了，事实证明，为新兴的大英帝国赢得了印度。所以这些伟大的场景长期以来一直受到赞誉。然而，我认为公平地说，认为这对世界必然是伟大的观点现在比以前更具争议性。所以，克莱夫在白厅有雕像，人们对此有怨言。你认为这是七年战争被普遍遗忘的原因之一吗？它现在是否以某种方式变得有问题，而对于前几代人来说可能并非如此？
The robust voice of Middle England is grumbling away in the background. But, I mean, that's the kind of issue, isn't it? That it's more complicated now, perhaps, than it was to celebrate someone like Wolfe or Andy Clyde. Yes, you're exactly right. I think there's two issues. One is it has fallen out of favour because it has been succeeded by other great wars, greater wars, which inevitably,
英格兰中部的强硬声音在背景中抱怨。但是，我的意思是，这就是那种问题，不是吗？现在庆祝像沃尔夫或安迪·克莱夫这样的人，可能比以前更复杂了。是的，你说得完全正确。我认为有两个问题。一个是它已经失宠了，因为它被其他伟大的战争所取代，更伟大的战争，这不可避免地，
like the way that Churchill obscures Lloyd George, who obscures Pitt the Younger and Palmerston. You know, I think in terms of historical memory, we kind of only have place for one particular kind of national military endeavour. And of course, Second World War looms so large today. But I expect that Second World War will go through this process that 70 Years War has gone through. I mean, our parents grew up, I mean, the 70 Years War was essential.
就像丘吉尔掩盖了劳合·乔治，劳合·乔治掩盖了小皮特和帕默斯顿一样。你知道，我认为在历史记忆方面，我们似乎只为一种特定的国家军事努力留有空间。当然，第二次世界大战在今天显得如此重要。但我预计第二次世界大战也会经历七年战争所经历的这个过程。我的意思是，我们的父母长大了，我的意思是，七年战争是必不可少的。
Wolf, I mean, G.A. Henty books. I had a bizarre upbringing of reading strange Edwardian books that were left around my grandma's house. Dan, you're not alone. Well, I think I'm among friends here, but I was kind of radicalised. I'm having to un-radicalise myself carefully as I enter middle age. I'm doing the opposite to many people's journeys. But I, Wolfe in Quebec, Clive in India were foundational stories people. And in a way way because they were
沃尔夫，我的意思是，G.A.亨蒂的书。我有一种奇怪的成长经历，读着我奶奶家周围留下的奇怪的爱德华时代的书。丹，你并不孤单。好吧，我想我在这里有朋友，但我有点被激进化了。我在进入中年时不得不小心翼翼地让自己去激进化。我正在做与许多人的旅程相反的事情。但我，魁北克的沃尔夫，印度的克莱夫是人们的基础故事。在某种程度上，因为他们是
I mean, Wolfe's victory at Quebec in short order delivered the whole of New France I mean very briefly, before the American Revolution we should remember, I mean the whole of North America virtually, apart from the new Spain which stretched up into A question from the splendidly maritime
我的意思是，沃尔夫在魁北克的胜利在短时间内交付了整个新法兰西，我的意思是，非常简短地，在美国革命之前我们应该记住，我的意思是，整个北美几乎，除了延伸到……的一个来自宏伟的海上声音的问题
sounding Jacob Hawkins If England had lost the Seven Years' War, do we still get the British Empire and or the War of Independence? So let's leave the War of Independence to one side. But the British Empire, I mean, basically, this is the war that creates the British Empire. As we recognise it, as the 19th century will understand it. So therefore, that's problematic in itself. That's not something for unalloyed celebration, which it was 100 years ago. There is this issue.
雅各布·霍金斯，如果英国输掉了七年战争，我们还会得到大英帝国和/或独立战争吗？所以让我们把独立战争放在一边。但大英帝国，我的意思是，基本上，这就是创造大英帝国的战争。正如我们所认识的那样，正如19世纪所理解的那样。因此，这本身就是有问题的。这并不是像100年前那样值得毫无保留地庆祝的事情。存在这个问题。
I mentioned Martinique, which is captured. guadeloupe i mentioned captured martinique in 1762 west west africa senegal you know these places in west africa are captured that's about the slave trade that's about the slave the trade and enslaved human beings vastly and amazingly amazingly there's this great moment where france has a canada or guadeloupe moment which has become a kind of celebrated thing in international um by um international affairs kind of studies, is that there's this moment when the French have to decide, do they ask for Canada back at the negotiating table or Guadeloupe? And they choose Guadeloupe, amazingly, the second largest country on earth now with vast oil, incredible wealth. It was rejected by Canada. People like Voltaire said it was a few acres of frozen snow and it was just the beavers.
我提到了马提尼克，它被占领了。瓜德罗普，我提到了1762年占领了马提尼克，西非，塞内加尔，你知道西非的这些地方被占领了，那是关于奴隶贸易，那是关于奴隶，奴隶贸易和被奴役的人类，非常令人惊讶，令人惊讶的是，有一个伟大的时刻，法国有一个加拿大或瓜德罗普时刻，这已经成为国际事务研究中一种著名的东西，那就是法国必须决定，他们在谈判桌上是要求加拿大回来还是瓜德罗普？他们选择了瓜德罗普，令人惊讶的是，现在地球上第二大国家，拥有巨大的石油，令人难以置信的财富。它被加拿大拒绝了。像伏尔泰这样的人说它只是几英亩冰雪，而且只有海狸。
It was just the hats that it was the only thing useful for so and that's because sugar was grown the super commodity of the 18th century sugar was grown by enslaved people on those islands hugely hugely profitable the trade derived the money the trade the the cash flowing into venture capitalist pockets in Britain as we have all rehearsed now we all know where the slave trade was hugely important within that development of the early of 18th century British economy, politics, society, all that stuff. So that's why it's difficult to celebrate. We now know more about Robert Clive. I mean, he was, I'm afraid, an unattractive character. He... Struggled with his mental health. I think that's how you'd rehabilitate him, isn't it?
它只是帽子，它是唯一有用的东西，所以这是因为糖是在那些岛屿上由被奴役的人种植的，糖是18世纪的超级商品，利润极其丰厚，贸易衍生了金钱，贸易，现金流入英国风险投资家的口袋，正如我们现在所排练的那样，我们都知道奴隶贸易在18世纪英国经济、政治、社会等所有这些事物的发展中非常重要。所以这就是为什么很难庆祝。我们现在对罗伯特·克莱夫了解更多。我的意思是，恐怕他是一个没有吸引力的人物。他……在心理健康方面挣扎。我想这就是你如何让他恢复名誉，不是吗？
Sorry, absolutely, that's correct. You'd say he was a martyr to his mental health. I think that's how you'd rehabilitate him, isn't it? Sorry, absolutely, that's correct. You'd say he was a martyr to his mental health. fighters it was just a gigantic bribery was you know there was there was cash exchange between um rogue uh indian um sort of magnates and east india company and and people like that so it is it is harder to yeah of course do you do you think there's a case for saying that the the british empire and the conquest of vast swathes of the world was kind of incidental to the core british ambition which was to beat the french uh i think it was incidental this the core British ambition, which was to beat the French? I think it was incidental. This is a really wonderful question, because in terms of getting territory, as you guys know, painting the world pink was always quite unpopular by huge swathes of policymakers and people in Whitehall. It's really expensive. You get massive blowback.
抱歉，绝对，那是正确的。你会说他是他心理健康的殉道者。我想这就是你如何让他恢复名誉，不是吗？抱歉，绝对，那是正确的。你会说他是他心理健康的殉道者。战士们，这只是一场巨大的贿赂，你知道，在流氓印度大亨和东印度公司以及像那样的人之间有现金交换，所以这更难，是的，当然，你认为有理由说大英帝国和对世界广大地区的征服对英国的核心野心来说是偶然的，那就是打败法国吗？我认为这是偶然的，这是核心的英国野心，那就是打败法国？我认为这是偶然的。这是一个非常棒的问题，因为就获得领土而言，正如你们所知，把世界涂成粉红色一直受到白厅政策制定者和人们的极大反对。这真的很贵。你会得到巨大的反弹。
So for one great example, after the Seven Years' War, you get the British government say, right, we might now have conquered technically this bloody enormous area in North America, but they banned their British settlers, their North American settlers, from settling in the back country of Pennsylvania, which is a huge reason for the American Revolution. Because the Brits go, the last thing we want to do is control a kind of trans-American state. It's going to cost a ton of money. And the locals hate us.
所以举一个伟大的例子，在七年战争之后，英国政府说，好吧，我们现在可能在技术上征服了北美这片血腥巨大的区域，但他们禁止他们的英国定居者，他们的北美定居者，在宾夕法尼亚的偏远地区定居，这是美国革命的一个巨大原因。因为英国人说，我们最不想做的事情就是控制一种跨美国的国家。这要花一大笔钱。而且当地人讨厌我们。
And you get this Pontiac's Revolt. You get North American natives fighting the Brits and fighting these settlers. And so it is, as the great expression, that British Empire in Africa was acquired in a kind of a fit of absence of mind, when all their treasure was to protect the Suez Canal. So I think there is an element that Europe, a good old fashioned sense of power politics within Europe,
然后你有了庞蒂亚克起义。你有了北美原住民与英国人战斗，与这些定居者战斗。所以正如那句伟大的表达，非洲的大英帝国是在一种心不在焉的状态下获得的，当时他们所有的财富都是为了保护苏伊士运河。所以我认为有一个因素是欧洲，一种欧洲内部老派的权力政治感，
and also the British wanted to get rich. And in those days, getting rich had a mercantilist element to it. It was thought you had to control the islands of the Caribbean to take advantage of this trade in sugar. It should be British ships carrying that sugar. They should be crewed by British crews. They should use British ports. They should cross ship to other ships that then export it to Europe. So, yes, to beat the French, but it was about money and economic clout as much as beating them on a battlefield.
而且英国人也想致富。在那些日子里，致富有一种重商主义的成分。人们认为你必须控制加勒比海的岛屿才能利用这种糖贸易。应该是英国船只运送那种糖。它们应该由英国船员配备。它们应该使用英国港口。它们应该转运到其他船只，然后出口到欧洲。所以，是的，为了打败法国，但这与金钱和经济影响力有关，就像在战场上打败他们一样。
But, Dan, there's this argument, isn't there? Brendan Sims has this argument, Cambridge historian, that the way we think about Britain and its world role and the evolution of the empire and the Seven Years' War as a foundational moment in that is all wrong
但是，丹，有这个论点，不是吗？布伦丹·西姆斯有这个论点，剑桥历史学家，我们思考英国及其世界角色以及帝国演变和七年战争作为其中的基础时刻的方式都是错误的
because we're looking at Canada and we're looking at India and he argues that the action was all really in Europe and that Europe was what mattered to British policymakers, that we've sort of written that out of history and that we're too obsessed with the kind of global Britain,
因为我们看着加拿大，我们看着印度，他认为行动实际上都在欧洲，欧洲对英国政策制定者来说才是最重要的，我们已经把那部分从历史中抹去了，我们太沉迷于那种全球英国，
and that we don't realise how much the establishment cared about Europe above all. Could I just mix that point in with a question from Stephen Clarke, good friend of the show? Did the Seven Years' War establish Prussia as a great power? So that is always the other aspect of the Seven Years' War to keep in mind, is the Prussian dimension. Well, Tom, well done, Stephen Clarke, and well done, Tom,
而且我们没有意识到当权者对欧洲的关心程度高于一切。我能把这一点和斯蒂芬·克拉克的一个问题结合起来吗，节目的好朋友？七年战争是否确立了普鲁士作为一个大国？所以这始终是七年战争中需要记住的另一个方面，是普鲁士维度。好吧，汤姆，做得好，斯蒂芬·克拉克，做得好，汤姆，
for that very lovely segue of marrying everyone together. We're all singing in harmony now, but Dominic, you're absolutely right. And of course, what's interesting, we all, in 1910, when the British Empire did cover 20, well, 1920, when it covered 25% of the Earth's landmass, clearly these campaigns were talking about General Wolfe in Quebec, feels vitally important in that story. Now that we're looking at a Europe dominated by Germany, and a world in which the British Empire no longer matters or exists, we suddenly think,
为了那个把每个人都联系在一起的非常可爱的过渡。我们现在都在和谐地歌唱，但多米尼克，你是完全正确的。当然，有趣的是，我们所有人，在1910年，当大英帝国确实覆盖了25%的地球陆地面积时，显然我们正在谈论的这些战役，魁北克的沃尔夫将军，在那个故事中感觉至关重要。现在我们看着一个由德国主导的欧洲，以及一个大英帝国不再重要或不存在的世界，我们突然想到，
oh, you know what, maybe that whole Frederick the Great thing was a bit more important than we were noticing, which of course is exactly what King George II and the Duke of Newcastle were primarily focused on. They were focused on the balance of power in Europe. They wanted to access, they did not want a hegemonic power emerging in Europe. They assumed it would be the French, and they wanted therefore Frederick the Great, this kind of useful North German counterweight to Austro-French power in Europe. Now, of course, Prussia doubles in size during his rule. Funnily enough, during the Seven Years' War, it actually doesn't. It's more like he's tested by the most astonishing.
哦，你知道吗，也许整个腓特烈大帝的事情比我们注意到的要重要一些，这当然正是乔治二世国王和纽卡斯尔公爵主要关注的事情。他们关注的是欧洲的权力平衡。他们想要进入，他们不希望欧洲出现一个霸权国家。他们假设那将是法国，因此他们想要腓特烈大帝，这种有用的北德反制力量来对抗欧洲的奥法权力。现在，当然，普鲁士在他的统治期间规模翻了一番。有趣的是，在七年战争期间，它实际上并没有。更像是他受到了最令人震惊的考验。
As I said at the beginning of the podcast, he's hardened by fire in the Seven Years' War. He gained Silesia at the beginning of the War of Austrian Succession, which actually, as you know, is probably the most important thing to ever tap in the history of Europe, because that's where the rot sets in. I mean, if you want to, you know, Prussia, the most important thing to ever tap in the history of Europe, because that's where the rot sets in. I mean, if you want to, you know, Prussia, the end of Austria-Hungary, the slow decline. I mean, him seizing Silesia in 1740 from the young Austrian new ruler, Maria Theresa, is the moment when everything turns.
正如我在播客开头所说，他在七年战争中在火中淬炼。他在奥地利王位继承战争开始时获得了西里西亚，这实际上，正如你们所知，可能是欧洲历史上发生的最重要的事情，因为那是腐烂开始的地方。我的意思是，如果你想，你知道，普鲁士，欧洲历史上发生的最重要的事情，因为那是腐烂开始的地方。我的意思是，如果你想，你知道，普鲁士，奥匈帝国的终结，缓慢的衰落。我的意思是，他在1740年从年轻的奥地利新统治者玛丽亚·特蕾莎手中夺取西里西亚，是事情发生转折的时刻。
It's the fulcrum. There's probably some Julius Caesar moment you could give me about him becoming Pontifex, whatever it was, Tom. But that's kind of the moment. And the Seven Years' War reinforces that conquest maria theresa goes all out she bankrupts she sells her jewelry she goes all out to get silesia back she defends bohemia but she and she doesn't get silesia back frederick's allowed to keep his gains in europe and they will expand as he starts to
这是支点。可能有一些尤利乌斯·凯撒的时刻你可以告诉我关于他成为大祭司的事情，汤姆。但那基本上就是那个时刻。七年战争加强了那次征服，玛丽亚·特蕾莎全力以赴，她破产了，她卖掉了她的珠宝，她全力以赴夺回西里西亚，她保卫了波希米亚，但她没有夺回西里西亚，腓特烈被允许保留他在欧洲的收益，随着他开始
partition poland later on so so prussia now and sitting now in the 21st century when when germany is a significant thing and it is derived from that prussian uh that prussian experiment that prussian success the 18th century you can say yeah we should probably be thinking more about europe um than in the seven years war it i mean it is amazing to think of that to think of of the the kind of the the europe of of today as being set in the Seven Years' War, but also the spread of Anglophone culture, the fact that the United States of America speaks English, that India is an English-speaking country. Imagine if Canada was French as a counterweight, as a linguistic, cultural counterweight to the US, Tom. You know, if there was a Canadian Hollywood that waswood that was french speaking i mean well like well the
后来瓜分波兰，他们会扩张。所以普鲁士现在，坐在21世纪，当德国是一个重要的事情时，它源于那个普鲁士实验，那个普鲁士成功，18世纪，你可以说，是的，我们可能应该更多地考虑欧洲，而不是七年战争。我的意思是，想到这一点，想到今天的欧洲是在七年战争中确定的，这真是太神奇了，但也包括英语文化的传播，美利坚合众国说英语的事实，印度是一个讲英语的国家。想象一下，如果加拿大是法语的，作为一种反制力量，作为一种语言、文化反制力量来对抗美国，汤姆。你知道，如果有一个加拿大的好莱坞是讲法语的，我的意思是，好吧，世界会
world would be utterly culture would be so yeah dominic samberg i sense is not a fan of the wonderful and very very dynamic montreal film scene uh and uh a film scene of which i was hitherto unaware barbarian invasions is one of the great films as a canadian citizen i don't know but but you're right and of course bismarck brilliant brilliant. My favourite quote about the Seven Years' War was Bismarck. The Anglophone stuff, the fact that people wazz on about Magna Carta more outside Britain than they do inside Britain. The fact that
世界会完全，文化会是，所以是的，多米尼克·桑伯格，我感觉到他不是那个美妙且非常有活力的蒙特利尔电影界的粉丝，以及一个我以前不知道的电影界，《野蛮入侵》是伟大的电影之一，作为一名加拿大公民，我不知道，但你是对的，当然，俾斯麦，辉煌，辉煌。我关于七年战争最喜欢的名言是俾斯麦。英语的东西，人们在英国以外比在英国内部更多地谈论大宪章的事实。事实上，
the Australians, the Indians, the Americans have got parliamentary traditions that date, that all stem from this fun little island of ours. All of that stuff, of course, the Seven Years' War makes that very important. And Bismarck island of ours all of that stuff of course is fun the seven years war makes that very important and bismarck brilliantly says at the end of the 19th century bismarck as you know he retired to his estate kaiser wilhelm kind of kicked him out
澳大利亚人、印度人、美国人都有议会传统，这些传统可以追溯到，都源于我们这个有趣的小岛。所有这些东西，当然，七年战争使这变得非常重要。而俾斯麦，我们的小岛，所有这些东西，当然，七年战争使这变得非常重要，而俾斯麦在19世纪末辉煌地说，俾斯麦，正如你们所知，他退休到他的庄园，威廉皇帝把他赶走了
and he was in a foul mood for the rest of his life and a young journalist i think it was went and said you know what do you think will be the most important you know when we're looking at the new the 20th century what what what is it that will really determine the course of the 20th century and bismarck answers immediately the fact that north america speaks english and he's exactly right you know the great the monumental battles of the 20th century first against um imperial germany then against fascism and then against communism are it is the it is that coalition of of of uh english speaking anglo-saxon capitalist economies that gather together and are able to overcome those and that is absolutely essential dan you are the arthur bryant of history clearly with this
他余生心情都很糟糕，我想是一个年轻记者去说，你知道，你认为什么会是最重要的，你知道，当我们看着新的20世纪时，什么才是真正决定20世纪进程的东西，俾斯麦立即回答，北美说英语的事实，他是完全正确的，你知道，20世纪伟大的、纪念碑式的战斗，首先是反对帝国德国，然后是反对法西斯主义，然后是反对共产主义，是那个讲英语的盎格鲁-撒克逊资本主义经济体联盟聚集在一起，能够克服这些，这绝对是必不可少的，丹，你显然是历史的亚瑟·布莱恩特，有了这个
english-speaking democracy sorry i know it's i know daniel hannan is listening he's getting a serious uh but but but but let's just, let's, we're coming to a close. So I've got two questions here, both of which, of course, put this back into an 18th century perspective. One of them is from Dr. Tony O'Donnell, and he asks, is the Seven Years' War,
讲英语的民主，抱歉，我知道，我知道丹尼尔·汉南在听，他正在得到一个严重的，但但但让我们，让我们，我们即将结束。所以我这里有两个问题，当然，这两个问题都把这放回了18世纪的视角。其中一个是托尼·奥唐奈博士问的，他问，七年战争是
the French and Indian War, America's forgotten creation myth, Washington and others leading a war that later taxes sought to repay and the colonials rejected the cost of their own defense um and then we have a great comment from uh jim zoo um lord newcastle was generally regarded as a buffoon in part over his staunch support for the anglo-austrian alliance that blew up and dragged europe into war 20 years later lord north lost america because of diplomatic isolation. Who's the greater buffoon in hindsight? So I guess both of those, that the roots of the the French go away and decide to try and compete with Britain at sea and spend unimaginable amounts of money doing so, like I said earlier, and directly contributes towards their bankruptcy. But also, the disaster of the American Revolution within Britain around the peace treaty, is what we don't want to do is become the new Louis XIV. We don't want to be the baddies, you know, that great sketch. Are we the bad guys?
法国和印第安战争，美国被遗忘的建国神话吗？华盛顿和其他人领导了一场后来税收试图偿还的战争，殖民者拒绝了他们自己防御的成本，然后我们有一个来自吉姆·祖的伟大评论，纽卡斯尔勋爵通常被视为一个小丑，部分原因是他对英奥联盟的坚定支持，该联盟在20年后爆炸并将欧洲拖入战争。诺斯勋爵因为外交孤立而失去了美国。事后看来，谁是更大的小丑？所以我猜这两个，法国人离开并决定尝试在海上与英国竞争，并为此花费了难以想象的钱，就像我之前说的那样，并直接导致了他们的破产。但同样，美国革命在英国围绕和平条约的灾难，是我们不想做的事情是成为新的路易十四。我们不想成为坏人，你知道，那个伟大的小品。我们是坏人吗？
So they were terribly nervous about appearing to be a European hegemon. And I think they largely failed in that because they thought they'd give a bit more back to France on the peace treaty. That would avoid them being unpopular. They actually kind of failed at both. They neither held on to everything, nor did they stop this overwhelming oppression. Britain was now the problem in Europe. And so, for example, the Dutch, other European nations, when it comes to the War of Independence, they're either neutral, pretty hostile neutral, or they back the Americans.
所以他们非常担心看起来像是欧洲霸权。我认为他们在很大程度上失败了，因为他们认为他们会在和平条约上给法国多一点回报。那会避免他们不受欢迎。他们实际上在两方面都失败了。他们既没有坚持住一切，也没有阻止这种压倒性的压迫。英国现在是欧洲的问题。所以，例如，荷兰人，其他欧洲国家，当谈到独立战争时，他们要么中立，相当敌对的中立，要么支持美国人。
But in a more direct sense... Did the Portuguese stay with us? The Portuguese in the American Revolutionary War, I don't know about that. We'll check that out. Yeah. I'm sure they did. I don't know. They would never let us down, the Portuguese.
但在更直接的意义上……葡萄牙人留下来了吗？葡萄牙人在美国独立战争中，我不知道。我们会查一下。是的。我相信他们会的。我不知道。他们永远不会让我们失望，葡萄牙人。
The Portuguese would never let us down, no. And I think, but in a very direct sense, of course, the American, the Seven Years' War is the American foundation myth, because you do that terrible thing, which is you remove the threat. And the American colonies had lived under the
葡萄牙人永远不会让我们失望，不。我认为，但在一个非常直接的意义上，当然，美国，七年战争是美国的建国神话，因为你做了那件可怕的事情，那就是你消除了威胁。美国殖民地生活在
dagger of French and Native American, Native Americans only, you know, miles from the eastern, the big cities of the eastern seaboard. And the American colonies had lived under the dagger of French and Native American. Native Americans only, you know, miles from the big cities of the eastern seaboard. Montcalm comes very close to the big settlements of the eastern seaboard. The French are now gone. Britain controls the continent. The Native Americans have no allies anymore. They are terribly bereft. And they are then, as we know, an awful story, dystopian story, what happens to them. And so there's this great quote from an American, a British governor,
法国和美洲原住民的匕首下，只有美洲原住民，你知道，离东海岸的大城市几英里。美国殖民地生活在法国和美洲原住民的匕首下。只有美洲原住民，你知道，离东海岸的大城市几英里。蒙卡尔姆非常接近东海岸的大定居点。法国人现在走了。英国控制了大陆。美洲原住民不再有盟友了。他们非常丧失。然后他们，正如我们所知，一个可怕的故事，反乌托邦的故事，发生在他们身上的事情。所以有一个来自美国人的伟大引语，一位英国总督，
of a colonial governor, and he said, you know, what did British gain? And I think he said from the most glorious and successful war which she has ever engaged upon. And that she gained an empire that she was unable to defend, maintain or govern, because she then had this giant empire that she couldn't pay for, and Britain tried to tax the American colonists for their protection. In my opinion, entirely reasonably, all right? Anyway, so a standing military force was now required to protect this
一位殖民总督，他说，你知道，英国获得了什么？我想他说，从她曾经参与过的最光荣和最成功的战争中。她获得了一个她无法防御、维持或治理的帝国，因为她当时拥有这个她无法支付的巨大帝国，英国试图对美国殖民者征税以保护他们。在我看来，完全合理，好吧？总之，现在需要一支常备军事力量来保护这个
giant empire. They fell out with the Americans, and the Americans looked around and went, hold on a minute, I don't think we need the Brits anymore. You know, we do not need these guys protecting us. We have got all the advantages now of this giant hinterland let's shift the brits so so in a very real sense so massive ingratitude massive gratitude his tax dodge isn't it i mean that's what it is yeah well and and they all the virginia planters are enjoying this well all the we just lost that 20% of our audience. A tax dodge. No, don't worry, he'll come back.
巨大的帝国。他们与美国人闹翻了，美国人环顾四周，说，等一下，我不认为我们需要英国人了。你知道，我们不需要这些人保护我们。我们现在拥有这个巨大腹地的所有优势，让我们转移英国人，所以在一个非常真实的意义上，所以巨大的忘恩负义，巨大的感激，这是避税，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是它，是的，好吧，他们所有的弗吉尼亚种植园主都在享受这个，好吧，我们刚刚失去了20%的听众。避税。不，别担心，他会回来的。
And a tax dodge... It was not only a tax dodge, it was also a giant debt... You know, they didn't... The Virginia Planters, they're terribly indebted, Virginia Planters, London, basically went,
还有避税……这不仅是避税，也是巨大的债务……你知道，他们没有……弗吉尼亚种植园主，他们负债累累，弗吉尼亚种植园主，伦敦，基本上说，
we're not going to pay our debts now, we're going independent. So, yes, it was. Right, and on that sombre note, that sombre and disgraceful note i we've brought the seven years war to an end we've demonstrated that thackeray was talking nonsense yeah it's perfectly possible to explain the course of the seven years war tom we must never have we must never have dan snow back on this program again that is that is for
我们现在不打算偿还债务了，我们要独立了。所以，是的，它是。好吧，在那个阴郁的音符上，那个阴郁和可耻的音符，我我们已经把七年战争带到了终点，我们已经证明了萨克雷在胡说八道，是的，完全可以解释七年战争的进程，汤姆，我们绝不能，我们绝不能让丹·斯诺再回到这个节目，那是肯定的
sure he's been so rude yeah he, he's been rude about our audience. No, more than worth it. More than worth it, Dan. Can't thank you enough. And I hope you've enjoyed the podcast. We will see you next week. Dominic, I think we're actually doing the French Revolution, aren't we? French Revolution and food.
他太粗鲁了，是的，他，他一直对我们的听众很粗鲁。不，非常值得。非常值得，丹。怎么感谢你都不为过。我希望你喜欢这个播客。我们下周见。多米尼克，我想我们实际上是在做法国大革命，不是吗？法国大革命和食物。
And food, yeah. Not in the same podcast. French Revolution is a kind of natural sequel to this. Yes, so what's happened next? And I think we'll do that. We're going to do that sans guest. Just us.
还有食物，是的。不在同一个播客里。法国大革命是这个的自然续集。是的，那么接下来发生了什么？我想我们会做那个。我们要不带嘉宾做那个。只有我们。
Yeah, just us. Sans Dan. I'm going to tune into that. That's going to be fantastic. Thanks so much, Dan. Thanks very much for listening. We will see you soon. Thank you, everybody.
是的，只有我们。没有丹。我要收听那个。那会很棒。非常感谢，丹。非常感谢收听。我们很快见。谢谢大家。
Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《剩下的就是历史》。如需额外剧集、提前访问、无广告收听和访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。